suivi ce matin en 2015 david labrie
s'est présenté à l'urgence en raison des
soufflement et de fatigue chronique à
l'institut de cardiologie de québec on
lui annonce qu'il a une insuffisance
cardiaque terminale et qu'il faut le
père et rapidement je ne croyais pas en
france c'est soit ça ou que je meurs je
te déclarer mort l'homme de 39 ans a
subi une première opération pour se
faire installer un coeur mécanique en
raison d'une complication
il a dû être opéré de nouveau pour lui
poser un autre pareille à cette époque
ces médecins n'avaient pas trouvé la
cause de sa maladie on savait que ce
n'était pas un trouble d'origine
cardiaque comme la très grande majorité
de ces patients c'est en voyant son état
s'améliorer que les cardiologues mario
sénéchal le demandait s'il prenait des
drogues dv2 l'abri lui alors annoncé
qu'ils consommaient des amphétamines
acheter sur le marché noir depuis quatre
ans bon je prends la soul c'est plus le
plaisir durant ces communes amateurs
premier de l'énergie cacher des émotions
et plus non plus pour le contenu et le
parti a franchement je dois vous avouer
de 5 à 10 ans on n'y pensait pas parce
que c'était beaucoup moins privé
maintenant c'est rendu un réflexe quand
un patient est un gène moins 45 heures
et puis qu'on n'a pas de cause on n'a
pas de cause coronarienne on évacue
rapidement le diagnostic de possibilités
de conservation d'une drogue entre
autres de l'amphétamine nouveaux cas
d'insuffisance cardiaque causée par les
amphétamines et traiter chaque semaine à
la clinique des suffisance kardec de
l'institut la plus importante au canada
ces patients âgés moins de 30 ans
représentent maintenant environ 10% de
l'ensemble de la clientèle
deux d'entre eux sont même décédée dans
les cinq dernières années le plus sec
lieu une explosion du nombre de codes
donc pour moi c'est un fléau c'est un
cri d'alarmé le réseau de la santé se
doit d'apporter de l'aide à ses patients
respire fort pour moi c'est un problème
de société c'est un problème de santé
publique
je pense que le message doit doit être
donnée aux gens qui consomment aux gens
qu'ils peuvent consulter au docteur qui
vont faire les diagnostics qui doivent y
penser plus rapidement
mais également pour le législateur
aucune prise en charge complète de ses
passes et au fait de la prévention dans
les dix dernières années une centaine de
cars mécaniques ont été installés à
l'institut 10% des cas étaient des
consommateurs de drogue dont la majorité
des amphétamines d'avis de la bri a été
parmi les premiers passants a bénéficié
d'un coeur mécanique pour cette raison
maintenant que son coeur va bien il en a
plus besoin
il n'a plus j'aime consommer
d'amphétamines gigantesque projet au
budget comme deuxième sur un favori si
david et tous les patients chez qui on a
installé un coeur mécanique où le
patient qui a été transportée silva pour
lui cette solution lithium il serait
tout décédée ici nicole germain radio
canada québec